Земля в Німеччині, як і славнозвісне пиво, сосиски
та автомобілі - товар, який, хоч і з певними нюансами,
але вільно купується, продається, а з роками стає лише дорожчим.
Ціна на недешеву землю
сільськогосподарського призначення зросла
в середньому по Німеччині за останні 10 років
більш ніж удвічі.
За даними федеральної статистики, найдорожчою є
земля в Баварії, де вартість одного гектара сягає
майже 65 тисяч євро. При цьому різниця в ціні
зі східними землями вражаюча: в понад 6 разів!
Так, приміром, у Тюрингії та Бранденбурзі
гектар коштує 10-11 тисяч євро. Середня ж вартість
гектарa сільськогосподарської землі в Німеччині
у 2018 році становила 25,5 тисяч євро.
Обмежень для іноземців немає - так само,
як і для фізичних чи юридичних осіб.
Ціни встановлює ринок. При цьому
для східних земель, які до падіння
Берлінського муру 30 років тому належали
до соцтабору, зробили певні винятки. Так, приміром,
встановлювалися спеціальні ціни для колишніх
власників земель, які в них забрали під час колективізації в НДР.
Такі фермери мали право сплатити приблизно 60%
від ринкової ціни землі. Іноді можуть бути
обмеження та певні вимоги, пов’язані
з особливостями ландшафтів та охороною навколишнього середовища.
Регуляція відносин власності на землю
значною мірою в компетенції регіональних органів влади,
і громади на місцях самі вирішують, чи варто робити
якісь обмеження на продаж чи купівлю паїв.
Загальна процедура купівлі землі виглядає так.
Перший крок - перевірка майнових прав
та обов’язкове оформлення угоди про купівлю-продаж у нотаріуса.
За ці послуги, як правило, сплачує покупець. Потім
нотаріально завірений договір разом із заявкою
на отримання дозволу купівлі землі в цьому районі
подається до місцевої влади. У чиновників є право
до трьох місяців вирішувати, чи надавати дозвіл.
Зокрема перевіряється пріоритетність
інших претендентів у купівлі тієї чи іншої ділянки.
Приміром, фермер має першочергове право купити
сусідню земельну ділянку. Якщо ж ідеться
про невеликі наділи, то дозвіл не потрібен.
Як правило, це ділянки від 0,15 до 2 гектарів
залежно від конкретного регіону. Податок
на придбання землі - до 4% від вартості угоди
і зазвичай сплачується покупцем.
Щоб не було спекуляцій і скуповування ріллі
за безцінь, ринок землі в Німеччині намагаються
регулювати максимально прозоро. Окрім того, є
незалежні комісії експертів з оцінки землі.
Вони ведуть бази даних про суми угод продажу ділянок.
Це є одним із факторів ціноутворення
для запобігання спекуляціям. Утім, проблема
концентрації земель у руках інвесторів, які вбачають
у цьому лише джерело прибутку, в Німеччині теж є,
хоч і не так гостро, як у деяких країнах Східної Європи.
Переважна більшість аграрних підприємств
- понад 70% - сімейні ферми, більшість із них
обробляють поля розміром від 5 до 50 гектарів.
При цьому більше половини сільськогосподарських
земель у Німеччині належать не фермерам,
а великим інвесторам.